we have this tweet from deplorable for
Trump 2024. saying Biden was caught on a
damning hot mic in Poland after
commenting on three UFOs shot down
saying you think any of these guys
bought that bullish hey totally they'll
buy anything let's get out of here let's
let me play the audio for you let's uh
here you go scientific research
[Music]
yeah those guys will believe anything it
is that is that 100 True like no so
the Twitter says it's a deep fake I
think obviously it's a deep fake the
problem is you can't prove a negative I
don't know where this video came from
someone posted it on Twitter people are
saying it's fake and it's like well you
can say it's fake
but how do you prove a negative
you would think that there'd be some
kind of signature detection that you
could run on an actual deep fake piece
of media that would be able to detect it
except you could
auto-generate fake voices and video and
then re-compress or render it so that it
Smooths all those things out you could
that's why it's probably so blurry they
were trying to make it look like it's a
recording of a recording so you can't
see the blemishes I think it's obviously
fake apparently PJ media rented as a
real story well that's what I was gonna
say it's obviously fake because Biden is
not slurring that when his voice takes
it again I know that sounds ridiculous
but if you listen to Biden he is muffled
in his speech whenever you see here an
AI generated uh Recreation of his voice
it's much clearer probably because it's
taking audio from now a long time ago
but the fact that then somebody's gonna
pick up the story and say well this is
going to get that Biden says Oh They'll
believe anything and then another media
Outlet picks it up and another one picks
it out another one that's how they make
it true now you heard that one but this
one's even more damning wait till you
hear this this uh deep fake leaked audio
from Andrew at don't walk run
Productions listen to this thank you
Poland thank you thank you thank you for
what you're doing
a moment from Biden
[Music]
children I was promised
give me our lifeblood
wow can you believe Joe Biden said that
no I think Andrew is just making fun of
the fact that people believed that that
clip was uh was real yeah I mean the
problem is that that you everyone's
gonna have the ability to sort of deny
things that they really said and claim
right that it's defect I mean here's the
crazy thing how can you use a recording
in a court of law a judge is not an
expert and doesn't care I will tell you
this right now
there we are entering territory where oh
you want to talk about murders you want
to talk about criminal cases fine
there's going to be a really difficult
constitutional question we saw with Kyle
Rittenhouse when they were flying the
Drone footage they're like look at this
video and then the defense had argue
like that is not a real image an
algorithm is creating the image when you
zoom in that image doesn't exist and and
they're like what does that mean we
don't know what that means now that's
that's a criminal case and there's
there's going to be challenges brought
up but even then it's hard hard to say
that's not real and you got to get an
expert in and then they'll argue experts
lying in a civil case it won't even get
that far in a civil case you'll go to a
judge and say Here's a video of Ian
admitting he owes me money and they're
just gonna go okay
Ian Pam and you're gonna be like that's
a fake video don't you get out of here
it's not a fake video there's like what
are you gonna do how do you prove it's
not real yeah I I I tell you this right
now when it comes to civil cases judges
are right gonna be like I don't know I
saw a video
and you're gonna bag and be like that is
not real well and instead of the being
Presumed Innocent right the person who's
being accused is gonna have to bring in
a bunch of experts to be like this is
where you can see possibly whatever if
they even can and so it becomes a very
difficult system it becomes faster to
set out of court especially in a
civilization and then you're going to
get cases where someone's gonna actually
say something
and then their lawyer is going to be
like you're in trouble you said this on
recording let's find a forensic expert
who will testify it's a deep fake they
go to the first friends that guy and he
goes that's a real real recording they
go to the next guy that's a real
recording they go to 20 guys and they
all say that's a real recording finally
the final one guy who says uh how much
are you paying me to go and testify
we'll pay you five thousand dollars oh
yeah oh that's totally a deep fake
can I have my money now yeah well after
you go to court okay then he's gonna
show up and he's just gonna say it he's
gonna say yeah here's why it's a deep
fake here's why I think can I get paid
now and then the Court's gonna have to
be like well I don't know is it a d fake
or not
is there any precedent so far with that
actually happening
um
I have heard stories where
I I there's there's there's been nothing
substantive there's just scuttlebutt
murmuring because the Deep fake stuff is
new but you know let me just say
I've heard stories so you think where
it's going is that media admissibility
as evidence is going to kind of go out
the window do you like do is it is it
even is it are we just going to go back
in time where it's all like it's so
pervasive yeah it becomes not even
invisible deep fake technology is going
to get so good that video evidence and
audio evidence will probably become
inadmissible in my opinion you'll go to
Cornwall back here's a video of the guy
of the murderer stabbing someone and
they'll go that's not real that was AI
generated so and an expert's going to
come in and say please to the jury
please this is clearly a fake video
watch and then there will be like an
artifact or something in the video and
I'll say see that blemish I have been
doing this work for 20 years I am
telling you that it's not real they are
tricking you this man is innocent and
during there's gonna be it's it's going
to be a reasonable doubt the fact
remains that if the technology exists
Reasonable Doubt exists and the and the
lawyer is going to be like you heard
from a forensic specialist this video
was doctored it is a deep fake video
they're gonna have to come in and be
like where was the video file generated
and they're gonna have to bring in the
computer they're gonna have to show deep
forensics so expensive and then even
then you can still have a forensic
expert say I know they're showing you
the stuff but they are wrong and that's
reasonable doubt you could have a
network of cameras that are all taking
an image of something that upon review
you'd see the angles of all the cameras
where they're located where the action
is happening the guy's body is he's
punching the woman on the ground or
whatever because police body cams are
going to be like nope deep thick can't
use it home security cameras no they
can't use it but if you have eight
security cameras all trying or all
angulating at one thing and you can
verify that each one verifies all the
other ones you would have to either
argue the entire network has been defect
or you can accept it you can easily deep
face if they were off network if they
were unrelated cameras that weren't on a
similar Network that all you'd have to
prove each of them was fake when we we
play video games we have created a 3D
environment of the character walking
around you can set Vantage points in 50
different locations and then you can in
in skater XL you can do a kickflip stop
time and then spin the camera all around
him if I wanted to I can play it front
to back 50 times from 50 different
angles and be like look I have 50
different cameras showing all the same
thing it's a real video so should we
take steps to restrict AI I mean should
we take steps to you can't it's like
trying to ban guns 3D printed guns exist
nothing you can do about it
apparently Facebook and Google have been
intentionally holding back a lot of the
text to video prompts technology because
of how disruptive it is have you seen
the the text to video AI
advertised a little bit it's crazy it's
crazy you type in video walking down a
dark path through a forest at night and
it makes a video right like it doesn't
do people as well well that we've seen
it's like it's very give it three years
it'll do a full feature film in perfect
quality based on your prompt
that's crazy yeah and what would I mean
what's the benefit for because to me
this sounds horrible and like it's gonna
make everyone's lives worse but if you
like this kind of Technology what's your
argument for it
I mean as an artistic tool it's like
undeniably powerful why because you're
not creating anything yourself it's
creating it for you that that seems like
it would take away the Artistry it does
somewhat I mean there's a whole AI
debate I I think that there's absolutely
value to fully human produced media and
that is always going to have a market
that's probably always going to be the
most valuable but in terms of like what
people watch or like what is most
stimulating and interesting we don't we
don't know I mean there's because it
it's not purely computer generated I
mean what is powering the eye human
media so it's it's more so it is a tool
but you know some people think that it's
is disempowering creators and it will do
that but it will also Empower creators
so it's it's very nuanced it's not what
do you see it what do you see the
benefits of this kind of AI
I mean it's kind of like asking what is
the benefit of a search engine
I mean you know we know the benefit of a
search engine it changed the world we
can look up whatever we want to at any
moment and that's kind of what it is
enabling you know we're seeing with chat
gbt and and others but that's heavily
censored and ideological and so what
would be the benefit of like deep faking
someone's voice like like what what does
that technology allow us to do because
to me it only seems like it can be used
for malicious purposes no I mean well I
mean for comedy for art like there's
definitely use what's his name uh Kyle
Dunnigan he does this he does the
funniest it's like it's very bad quality
deep fake stuff but I love Joe Biden
yeah not of job of Joe Biden but many
everybody else yeah he rips on and it's
like it's so funny and it's
but I think part of why it's funny is
because the Deep fakes are bad
so them getting better would actually
make that I don't know I can't say you
can't I mean do you see the one I
tweeted the me with Crowder and Ben
Shapiro deep fake
it's intentionally bad and weird and
creepy but it's really funny thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time